Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
Arrow came back from Olympics hiatus and wasted
no time picking up the pace.
We got more River Song, Robert Knepper playing
a character from the comic books, two major
plot lines set up a long time ago were paid
off and we got some of the best Felicity scenes
of the season.
In all fairness this really was her episode.
Also quick Flash Spin off shoutout.
They’ll be filming the pilot starting next
week.
So I’m going to wait to do a video till
then.
Hopefully there will be lots of great behind
the scenes pictures.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get it.
I am still doing my weekly Arrow Q&A tomorrow
though.
Now since there were so many good things in
the episode let’s do top 5 moments, then
I’ll do a breakdown of the comic book references
and my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode.
But Number 5 - Oliver and Sarah go everywhere
together now.
The funniest part of this is that his own
daughter is standing right in front of him
and he still doesn’t know who they are.
I loved that Oliver even referred to himself
in third person.
This is going to keep happening this season
and hopefully into season 3 if the Birds of
Prey development continues like the showrunners
are planning.
Number 4 - Felicity Training Session.
What are you wearing.
Emilly Bett Rickards actually said that she’s
not jealous of Oliver and Sara in a traditional
way, but she is upset at the thought of losing
the closeness that they have.
It’s pretty clear that Sara saw through
it all and since they’re destined to become
the Birds of Prey I’m really looking forward
to how they deal with it.
I’m sure Felicity will get through it with
plenty of Wushu and punching.
It’s really just fun to see her see some
action away from her computer console.
It would have been a little more fun if she
had been wearing batgirl colors though.
Since it’s kind of implied she’s going
to become the Oracle character.
Number 3 - The Stunts.
Most notably during the climax at the bank.
Oliver sliding down staircases backwards while
shooting arrows.
Felicity taking a bullet mid-air while blowing
up Clock King.
James Bamford is the stunt coordinator so
he’s responsible for the awesome fight scenes.
You may remember him from Stargate Atlantis
and all the awesome fights Jason Momoa got
to have.
Number 2 - Felicity Vs Sara Science Off.
The blood analysis was just the most fun part
of the Felicity versus Sara story arc.
I felt so bad for her when it seemed like
Sara science’d her into submission.
That look on her face will live in tumblr
infamy forever.
I’ll say that felicity did get the last
laugh.
She saved Sara, took a bullet from her and
was still worried that she killed Clock King.
It’s like the writers want her to be a badass
without compromising her morals or getting
vicious like Sara.
and my Number 1 moment - Drunk Naked Felicity
Speechifying.
Everyone run for cover because this totally
made tumblr explode.
It’s amazing at how the show damages their
relationship and then puts it back together
in an instant.
I can’t wait to see the outtake reel from
this scene.
Just the part where she fumbles over her words.
I would like to thank Diggle and I would like
to thank oxycotin for this wonderful performance.
Somebody needs to give Felicity a drunk Oscar.
It’s like the normal Oscars, but only for
performances given while you're drunk.
one last bonus best moment - Slade reveals
himself publicly.
He’s not hiding or appearing to Green Arrow
first, he went to Moira.
Probably to get involved with her run for
Mayor.
He’s really just letting Oliver know that
he can kill them all at any moment.
The teaser for the next episode featured scenes
that pick up directly where this last scene
left off.
So we won’t have to wait long to see what
the quote unquote Promise between them is.
So let me know what your favorite moment was.
I know, we’re all thinking the same thing.
You’ll always be my girl.
It’s just too much.
Here are all the references I saw, there were
a few really important ones.
Starting with Kord Industries.
This was where William Tockman, the Clock
King worked.
They’ve mentioned Kord Industries in so
many different episodes including Grant Gustin’s
Flash episodes, that I’m wondering if they’re
laying the groundwork for Ted Kord to guest
star on the show in Season 3.
And then eventually the Blue Beetle.
Then there was Sara’s Bar, Oblivion.
This is the home base of Shadowpact and it
exists in a pocket dimension that overlaps
with several other universes.
So it’s like a nexus of the multiverse where
you can grab a drink and hire a magic user.
Then there was Alex Kingston talking about
being a history professor in Central City
and having another man.
The easy one is the professor River Song reference,
meaning that other man could be The Doctor
and Central City is where the Flash show will
take place.
So her character could also be a backdoor
to bring Arrow people onto that show.
Overall I gave the episode an A minus for
excellent use of Emily Bett Rickards and because
it paid off the Sin storyline and Slade.
They’ve been teasing a Villains arc on the
show that’s going to start soon and cross
four or five episodes.
For a show that has to fill an hour of time
every week and has 23 episodes Arrow does
such an amazing job of weaving in new characters
and side stories that keep it feeling fresh
every week.
To be fair to other shows like Supernatural,
it’s been around for 9 years.
So I don’t expect the same things from it.
The only thing that felt out of place in this
episode was Thea, it felt like if you had
cut all her lines nothing about the story
would have changed.
And the call she made to Oliver at the end
felt like it was either Slade hacking her
phone or something the writers created purely
as a reason to get him into the house while
Slade was there.
Let me know what you thought of the episode.
I’m posting my Arrow Q&A tomorrow like normal
and next week is the promise, be sure to subscribe
to get my video.
I’m also posting a ton of other videos from
now until Sunday.
I’ve got a special South Park Stick of Truth
Giveaway I’m doing, this week’s Supernatural
and a super fun Game of Thrones video that
will cover stuff all the way back to season
1.
Right now click here for the last episode
of Arrow and click here for that Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!